did you know they're making a new
resident evil we haven't seen this
beloved storied horror franchise since
well anyway they're making a new one the
eighth mainline game in the series in
fact
simply titled resident evil village
thanks to capcom's recent showcase we
now have a
pretty good idea of what the game is
from what it's about
to how it plays to when it's coming out
spoilers
it's really soon this video is going to
tell you everything you need to know
about resident evil village
and maybe you'll learn why everyone is
super thirsty for that very tall vampire
lady
if you find this video useful we'd
really appreciate a like and sub
but hey the fact that you're here
already means a lot
now let's talk resident evil
village is a follow-up to 2017's
resident evil 7
biohazard and you are once again set in
the shoes of ethan winters village takes
place a few years after the events of
the baker mansion
and ethan and his wife mia have settled
down after all that
madness and getting busy apparently
because they have a
child now a daughter in fact side note
resident evil 7 has two endings one
where mia dies
and one where she lives the mia lives
ending has become the canonical ending
that village goes off of
the plot kicks off when ethan's home is
invaded his daughter
kidnapped and mia seemingly murdered
ethan's quest to save his daughter leads
him to the titular
village but who took his daughter and
why
well it's looking like series poster boy
chris redfield is responsible
why chris has long been the series
lawful good
boy scout sure he's had his low points
but he always rises to the occasion to
do what's right and
punch his way through large boulders and
into our hearts
which makes the horrible actions he's
committed against ethan's family
all the more shocking why chris has gone
off the deep end like this will no doubt
be one of the game's
biggest mysteries the box art of the
game shows the brooding face of redfield
mirrored with a
werewolf does chris turn into a werewolf
cause
that would be incredible it's entirely
possible that this
isn't even the real chris redfield after
all he's looking a lot
beefier than the last time we saw him
but also
that chris is slimmer than the one
punching the boulder
but that chris is different from the one
in code veronica which to be perfectly
frank looks
nothing like this guy and you know what
chris's true role as a villain or hero
is still left up for debate but we still
have a very clear-cut villain in lady
demotrescu
well ethan winters you escaped
my little brother's idiot games did you
she is the owner of a
massive castle that looms over the
village the common people are
terrified of the place and demitrescu
and as we've seen from the recently
released
maiden demo those who enter the castle
don't leave
also we have her three terrifying
daughters who possess the ability to
turn into a swarm of bugs
and want nothing more than to string
ethan up and eat them alive
man blood also mentions a younger
brother who might possibly be this van
helsing looking [ __ ]
demotrescu and her family are seemingly
the ones behind the kidnapping of
ethan's daughter
all part of a ceremony for one mother
miranda
yes of course i understand the
importance of the ceremony
i won't let you down
so in the game you'll be exploring both
the demotrescue castle
and the surrounding village it's
designed to be one seamless map you can
explore
its overall size is yet to be seen but
there's meant to be a
greater emphasis on exploration than
previous resident evils
gameplay will be building off of the
first person nature of resident evil 7.
this time around
guarding takes even greater importance
to help ethan counter foes
and you have the option to push them
away if you're getting crowded
we've also seen a much greater variety
of enemies which is
excellent news for those that found the
molded in resident evil 7
a little one note we've got these
ghoulish looking boys wearing cloaked
rags and rocking swords and battle axes
in the castle dungeon
meanwhile in the village ethan is
attacked by a group of
beefy hairy werewolf-like men and one
massive
bushy bearded man with a giant hammer
who's given me big
executioner vibes from resident evil 5.
honestly the whole thing kinda feels
like resident evil 4
infused with bloodborne two of my
favorite games ever made
and i am here for it
if it's just looking window shop away
speaking of resident evil 4 village has
a merchant of its own
a lovely fellow known as the duke his
shop lets you buy and sell weapons and
ammo as well as purchase gun upgrades
just like in resident evil 4. also
returning is the tetris style inventory
management system
creating first aid meds is now done from
a new crafting menu
you can also craft ammo just like in
resident evil 3.
the game very much feels like a
collection of the resident evil
franchise's best ideas
fused into one game finally it's worth
mentioning that resident evil village
comes with a free
separate resident evil multiplayer game
called reverse
it's a six-person death match where you
pick your favorite character and
duke it out in iconic resident evil
locations such as the raccoon city
police department
ari vs another game in a long line of
capcom attempting
weird multiplayer focused resident evil
games will this be the one that finally
works out
we'll just have to wait and see
so when can you get your hands on the
game thankfully you only have to wait a
few months as the game releases on may
7th
originally village was only announced
for current gen systems
ie ps5 xbox series x s and pc
but it has now been confirmed for ps4
and xbox one
if that's still too long of a wait and
you're chomping at the bit to try it out
and you
happen to be one of the five people on
the planet that owns a ps5
then you can check out the exclusive
maiden demo it's described as a visual
showcase that is its own
separate experience not part of the full
game if you don't have a ps5
don't worry we capture the whole demo
and you can watch it
right here after this capcom is also
aware that
most people don't have a ps5 so there
will be a separate second demo released
on all platforms
sometime this spring so that's
everything you need to know about
resident evil village
so far it's shaping up to be not only a
fantastic follow-up to resident evil 7
but in many ways a follow up to the
mechanics and themes of
resident evil 4 which is really hard to
not get excited about
hopefully we'll get some hands-on time
with the game before its full release
so make sure to come back to gamespot
for that as well as our full coverage
and review
thanks for watching
you